The icing on the cake was an event where
I was still very new to Froster, where
I somehow had our
sales manager set up such a big buffet
for our customers and then
I said why is
n't there any of our product at all?
I mean this is a meal
for the customers and then he
told me so you all know there are things
that you eat and there are things that
you sell so according to the motto we
can't offer our own things
so it was  Really pretty absurd
and it really wasn't about the
food, it was just about
the machines being able to process it well,
getting a little cheaper
and that was actually getting worse every year
and it was such a spiral that the
quality got worse and worse and then we
had to  we make it even cheaper
because even fewer people
had bought it and so we said it could
n't go on and that's how
this purity law
came about hi yes hello um is correct
or third generation now exactly
my father um was actually
a textile entrepreneur and and  Then he took a stake
in fishing companies in Bremmerhaaven
and that's what I would
say today, our company was founded in
1900 54. He still went to school, he has
a fresh fish troller Maria
from Jefa because he was born in Jefa,
but that Maria from  called jeeva and
then in the years up to
1960 he had 67 trollers, two of which were
factory ships that also
froze the fish straight away.
That all sounded or sounds quite good, what
he did there only had
a big disadvantage, the
fresh fish catchers made losses  and
you couldn't sell deep kelfish really well back then
and so
he asked me. I
actually wanted to do something completely different. I
wanted to do an apprenticeship here in Hamburg. I
actually wanted to go out
into the big wide world and get
involved with schiffard and then  He
persuaded me to go to Briemhaaven,
just like Bremmerhaaven, um, and um,
to help him a little bit to get out of these losses
and, um, that was a
difficult task and then I
first asked myself the question, yes, I do
n't know anything about fishing either.
I have to do that  Let's learn and then how do
you learn it best? You just go
with the trawler, they were called
at sea back then and then I went
once with the fresh fish vessel and
once with a ship that produced frozen fish
and the first trip
was in November
In 1960, with terrible weather,
I will never forget wind force 12 when I was
on the North Sea or at sea. Yes, I
caught fish in the North Sea, so I
caught fish with these trollers. They do
n't exist anymore today because the
nautical miles don't exist anymore
Iceland fished you could
get within three miles of Iceland and the
red bass and kabelau were and
mainly in the red BCH was
fished under Iceland and and and there you drive
north past Scotland past the
verröher and when then a
northwest storm wind force 12
then you really know what seafaring is
and I survived but I did
n't get seasick either,
fortunately I was already six years old
and I'm used to it and um yes and then
the trip goes to Iceland Erin I
still there today you could go so close to the
coast that  you
could see the Icelandic coast, you were really in the
suburbs, that does
n't exist anymore today, then first came the 500, the 50
mile zone, then the 200 mile zone,
so German fishing is completely
impossible there, but that's what it was back then and
that's what we have
But I still fished under storm conditions
and
caught redfish and they cooked the first redfish
in the galley themselves
and I don't eat GT redfish
bad and then it was an
experience right then I ate the
red basch as fresh as it came out of the water
and that's not
what I know as red basch but that's
exactly it if it's super fresh
then that's it  It was
incredibly good and tasty and
for me that was a kind of yes,
I actually already made the first
decision so fresh fish ca
n't actually
be a marketable product because you drive the troller
goes to Iceland for 7 days then it has to
fish for 10 days and then it leaves  It's 10 days 7
days back so it can't
be fresh at all while the fish that is
produced on these factory trollers on the factory ships is
frozen immediately after being caught and
then remains super fresh and
available as I said, only the problem comes
The freezer idea was basically then on the
troller that was actually the idea
I said I have to decide now
either the fresh fish troller
concentrate on fresh fish but
then on the trip I said yes
you can't do that with a fish
that has been on the move for so long and  It's on ice,
it's actually not a
marketable product, even though it
was quite common at the time because you
couldn't buy any other fish in the
fish shops like that and the deep fish
that was a bit innovative in that respect, what
this talking shop
did by my father that they did that
was a troller called sagita and he
filleted the first fish directly at sea for the first time and then
immediately froze it. Back then
in the 50s and 60s, nobody knew,
nobody knew what deep glüware
actually was, it was also unknown in
the shops  There were no deep cultures at all
and but still
I decided for
myself and said it ca
n't be fresh fish. We have to see that we can get out of
this fresh fish fishing business at some point
and the ships will
eventually sell and damage, which is what
we did later and  I
then wanted to concentrate fully on
frozen fish. That was
the hour of birth, so to speak,
but we didn't have a sales organization
and that was also the
hour of birth for me to found the
Froster company for my father
as the operating company
for Tiieff Forester  yes then we
also had a company that was called
seeforost but seefost wasn't such a
good name and foroster came from it
with my father so that he
mixed it up then I said
no Froster is a good name
and I got it straight away  had it registered
and protected so that in
1961 we already had this Froster brand
and then tried
to market the diefish, but later in
the trip at some point you
gave up the fishery completely
and only focused on the
distribution, so to speak, or that was exactly what it was
My goal wasn't that easy,
it took a few years to
get out of fishing because there were
n't any people who
made money with it and but I
said to myself that I now wanted to focus fully
on sales  However,
first of all, also on the production because what is
produced on this factory ship
are such large fillet blocks, um,
you can't
sell them in the store either, they first had to be
further processed and then we have them in
Briemmerhafen, that was the second
step  A
factory was built in Briemmerhafen, which was initially only for
fresh fish processing, but
I was the first to have
a department in this
building in Brimmerhafen where
the deep fish was
dismantled
The factory comes to Felix and then
he sees that it is actually a large sawmill.
These fillet blocks are
still being
sawn up and then
sold as small portions, or
even then the fish sticks are
made out. Fish sticks have to be made
This fish stick also comes from somewhere and
is just
sawn out of these fillet blocks and then
breaded but why was it better for you to let
other people catch the fish and then
just process it and
market it because they catch it,
so to speak, they catch the fish  itself is
economically attractive and I
let others do it no no that was
exactly my conclusion it
could already be seen back then
what surprised me was that some
large corporations like Unileva and ög they
built big frost trollers and then built such a troller
Somehow 20 million was
a lot of money back then, but as a newcomer I could
actually read in the newspapers
that Iceland and Greenland were aiming for the 200
mile zone and that's what
happened and at some point there was this raison d'être where
they had built huge ships that, thank God, I
couldn't  I still give excuses to my father,
he actually wanted to
build a ship like that, I say that's
total nonsense, let's try to
go out there and do exactly what
you said, let other people
catch and that's how it is today, so catch it
today  German trollers no
longer exist because there are no fishing grounds
but where we catch them today and
in the Pacific, for example Alaska Sex is one of the
biggest products that not only use as a
freezer now but also
other competitors that is
always there  where the big
seas are ultimately in the north but that is
far away from Germany and
Germany is no longer important
and today the goods are driven from Alaska,
so to speak, to you in Breberhafen
and then they are
processed directly and then further marketed by you
Exactly from the same
factory-made ones we
had back then, they've gotten a little
bigger now, but they're
caught at sea and then filtered directly at sea,
so it has
n't changed much from 60 years ago,
this technology is the same
You just have to freeze the fish as quickly as possible, like
with vegetables, it
has to be done as quickly as possible and then
it is processed and that
happens today just as it did 60 years ago.
You have to say that today you have a
company with a turnover of around 600 million euros
Of this, commitments are made to fish
processing and then distribution of fish,
about 40% 40% yes and the rest are
very large dishes and some of them also
vegetables and herbs okay okay and
have you then consciously tried to get out of the
fish in some way over the
years?  Not only did you
try to leave the catching of fish to others, but
you also
tried to reduce this fish issue yourself. Well, we did
have
problems with the fish because the
competition was great, but what
about this question again  to answer it to the end,
that was exactly my idea - we do
n't want to catch it ourselves -
others do it - it's a big capital tie-up and
I was able to get
the fish from other ships in Bremmerhafen that had all the
problems selling the fish
a lot of capital and that and yes and
I was
able to sell and sell these ships and so
when they were gone we only
concentrated exclusively on further processing and marketing and then there was a
certain problem
that the competition  was
Iglo Findus, they had a wider
range and only selling fish with one brand
and advertising it
wasn't a really good idea
and then I did that when
Felix was still almost at school,
I don't think or then I did  We
introduced ready meals
and but they weren't really of good quality
and today I asked myself again
what did I do wrong? I
started advertising with products that
weren't actually really good and
then despite the
advertising the profits went down and then we
have  We made losses and that was
actually the start of our
idea to introduce this purity law
and that's now we're talking about the beginning of
the 2000s, where I created purity birth
and that's
actually his part, I think that was the year of losses
that we had  In 2003
we made a loss of 7 million,
that was still my responsibility and
then Felix took over when they
put the company on the stock exchange. Yes, that's a
little different story. In 1984, I was
lucky enough
to buy the shares
that belonged to Jakobs and the then so-called Hochsfischerei Norddie  he also wanted
out of there the coffee jaobs he had more
then I took over the AG and
that was and then in 1984 and 88 I
brought in Frost here and this production company schotke there and so we were without
much effort
practically a listed
company and ST I still do today
and that's and then we
unnamed it, which was high for Nordstern at the time,
then we renamed it to
groceries Nordstern Grocery AG
and then we renamed it to
Froster AG so that if you go
into today  the register looks at Frost AG
when was it actually founded, that
is in 1905, so we already had
a hundredth anniversary,
but I have nothing to do with it, so
I say for myself we
actually started when my father had
this fish
built by jeever  It was
just 1954. I have to say your
entrepreneurial achievements are
gigantic because you agreed to take over a
small company from your father that
wasn't profitable and then,
so to speak, laid the foundation that
Felix has been saying for a few years now and
then did something about the frost
Today it's a real realization
and that was really
funny because I still remember that as a child and I
always came home and
always smelled like fish and that was
the time when Bremmerhafen
really had mainly fresh fish
and this was actually fresh fish  It was
n't really fresh, it was
just way too old and didn't taste good and
he just realized that he could turn this
fresh fish business into frozen
and because the potential was much
greater and the quality was much better,
that was actually the way it was and
it's really been that way ever since  We've
always dealt with a lot of things
but never with anything else that
isn't frozen, so we've always only used
frozen food because we said
it was the best way
to preserve food and without
anything else, just the cold and
but we're always through it now  The trade
is also your business, so
to a large extent you sell to
the trade and to the DIS, i.e.
food retail, which means
somehow both the edks and Revis as well
as all the discounters and you are
in between, I think the
discount share is also there  For you,
it's not small at all, no, it's good. Ultimately, to be
honest, as a consumer,
a discounter is the same. Whether I
go to Lidl, Aldi or Edica,
I don't really differentiate between them. As a consumer, that's what it
actually is for us  the same but we do
n't just do the trade we
also do a forester shop i.e.
we also do an online shop since
I
know we met not exactly and
and the funny thing is we do
n't know that but very few we
do and we also deliver  also the
catering industry, so we also have a
range that you wouldn't have if you often
go to a restaurant or go to a restaurant,
then you'll think that everything is freshly
cooked, but a lot of it was
frozen beforehand and
we deliver that too, but the breakdown is me
Now guess because Hal's trade
is generally so big, probably 80%
trade and the rest of the things are like
20% yes so yes 70 75 25 maybe through
thinking yes okay okay and in the trade
but different chains or or I
had all the chains yes yes  Of course, with Al,
they also grew up quite a bit, so
I read at least one article where you
had the feeling that things
were really moving forward in the 90s, also
thanks to Aldi, yes, of course, Aldi was the L
on it than Al, I think
They didn't have any
deep freezers for 20 years and at
some point they said we also needed
deep freezes and then of course we
grew even stronger and the company is now
essentially German. I know I have
sales offices abroad but how
much is it  German a lot of foreign countries
these days about 60 German 40
foreign and foreign means but other
European countries essentially in
Italy, which is actually the largest country
after Germany and then Austria and
and
Poland okay and I've been following a bit
so you've now built a brand
Froster but
e.g. a Captain Iglo has really appeared
massively in television advertising in
brand building so testimonial so every
child in my generation knows Captain
Iglo you didn't do that no no
we didn't have anything close to the
budgets that Unilever used to be
Unilever and that  Of course, they were
always ten times bigger than us. They could
always invest ten times more, so
of course they
already had a significantly higher level of awareness during that time,
which means that they are growing. The brand
is growing more or less through the
product and through distribution
and less through now  own
marketing activities exactly, of
course we are now doing a lot
more advertising, but as my
father just said at the beginning, the
product wasn't really that special yet
and that actually only
became special and worth promoting when we
introduced the purity birth,
write something  Is that exactly the same as
I did an apprenticeship as a cook and
then I came to Froster and
then there were a lot of funny
events, for example that nobody, we
produced lots of food and
just nobody ate it,
but we had a lot of
food chemists  but no
chefs at all and I only had a
culinary apprenticeship and said that it was somehow
strange here that the cooking here was just like
in my restaurant, on a large scale,
but somehow by food chemists
and not by chefs and so we
approached each other and said yes,
that's true  also because we have
a lot of chemicals in the products and have done so
for years and there was always such
a price round that we always
said it had to be a little
cheaper and then even
more real ingredients were replaced by
additives and that
Of course it was crazy for me with
my experience in the kitchen, so
you have to say you also
studied, I think exactly later. I
first did an apprenticeship as a chef because
I was somehow already interested in cooking as a child
and then I
did an apprenticeship as a chef and  After that I
studied, it was never
a problem for you that your son, so to speak,
after finishing school said okay, I'm going to do
an apprenticeship as a chef instead of somehow
getting into the company. No, I thought it was very,
very good, good, I still remember him
saying  Of course we
consulted
and go study or something.
No no, I don't want to have anything
to do with books anymore. I have to
do something crafty and I thought that was really
good, that of course it
ultimately went to our company and
someone who made food
If you do a cooking apprenticeship like that,
you can't really do that.
The funny thing is that my father
is never in the kitchen and
has never cooked, so I do
n't think I even saw that he
made scrambled eggs, but that was the case  I was
always exactly the opposite of
him, but since I also
did an apprenticeship, it was never an
issue, no, but the funny thing was
that we
did it so completely differently on a large scale
when I came to Forster than what I did
just when I was learning in the kitchen and
then I thought it can't actually
be, well and then the crowning moment
was actually an event where I
was still very fresh at Froster where I
somehow we have our
operations manager has something like that  We set up a large buffet
for our customers and then
I said why is there
no product from us at all? I
mean, this is a meal for
the customers and that's what he
told me, so you know, there are things
that  you eat and there are things that you
sell according to the motto:
we can't offer our own things,
so it was really
pretty absurd and it really was
n't about the food, it
was just about the machines being able to
process it well
become a little cheaper and
that actually got worse every year
and it was like a spiral, the
quality got worse and worse
then we had to make it even cheaper
because even fewer people
were buying it and so we said we could
n't go any further and so on  Then this
purity law was created, but when it was
done in the first year it collapsed by that amount
and that's exactly what we
developed for a long time and of course we
had an incredible euphoria because the
products were really really good
and really made the way you
cook at home  like I
learned in the restaurant and then
of course everyone thought that it was now selling
twice as much and that was the
opposite of that but of course it was more expensive,
you have to say that it was
more expensive per bag exactly and then we still
thought that it could with the taste  Yes, it
just works and the opposite, that
was of course our irturm. We
lived in our little bubble and
said how great it was.
Of course we didn't take
into account that we
had to convince millions of people and that of course took an
incredibly long time, but that was the first
year  exactly the year of loss that my
father said that we
had a loss of 8 million in the first year because
no one bought it anymore because they
didn't know why they should
spend more money on it now because it
wasn't immediately clear
Packaging, which
is actually different now mhm, it was a
very, very radical change and in
retrospect we completely
underestimated how long it takes to
educate millions of people about it and let them try it,
but now after 20 years it has
now been achieved, yes  That was 20 years
ago and it took a long time
for us to get back to the
level where we used to be and it
actually only worked because
people tried it and now
what is, so to speak, the product that
most people buy from you  What do you say about your
Euerag BR and butter product, what do they buy
from you? We
grew up with the paia. That was the
time when people always went to Spain
and then wanted to come back and
eat another paia at home, but
nowadays it's chicken friakisse  Okay, so
nothing with fish anymore, obviously
no, and exactly nothing with fish anymore,
then we have something like Big Goreng, so
a lot of international
dishes, but fish fingers are now
relatively large or actually
very large for us and
something like that  It's always like that, they're also
classics aha but always with
this requirement that we don't have any
additives, no flavors, anything
else in the
industry that's common in the market or is
it now so you've got the market
to that point  Do you
all do it like that or are you still
more in solitaire and the others are still putting
stuff in so
20 years ago I would say there was it was
completely full completely completely exceptional
and I still remember there we were also
the time where where  foodwch was created
and the foodw boss still says that it was great,
foodw Tilo Bode told me that
he would never be able to do that against the industry because
it was of course completely different to what
everyone else was doing and these
additives were created within 50
years so that they could  Industry
can produce cheaper and easier
and we then said we won't do that
anymore, we'll just do it
based on the model of how it is at home
or how it is in a restaurant and
a lot of people thought that wouldn't
work under any circumstances because we  Of course they
weren't more expensive, but we
did it in such a way that it wasn't good for the
machines but just the way
you eat it at home. Now
that means you have to be honest and say that if
I bought from a competition it would be
similar or something  it is still your
unique position no we are
with this very
consistent way we are really the
only ones I don't know anyone else so far
and it's because many people
can of course do that because they
don't have to declare a lot of things, which means
some things look relatively similar  But
if you look closely at the list of ingredients,
for us it is
really completely pure and without
anything, so others
probably couldn't do it so consistently
because they have so many products
where that doesn't work at all and
we think  that Forst is the
only company here where all
products are subject to this, so to speak,
Kinsgebot and that
if I were the boss of Iglo now
and would say yes, let's
just do that, it wouldn't be that easy
because the products are like
fish sticks or  what what sells Iglo
essentially no because they
are actually standard that are offered by the pre-industry of the
food industry
and the machines that you buy
for such products are also
set up for this, that is to say for your own painting, for
example if I have cream then
I always have karagen in it  The cream karagen
is a substance that ensures that
the cream does not become creamy, so in the past
you always had the frame
go up and down and
then somehow a bit of a
watery cream remains and that is the
standard cream that you buy  In
industry it is always with karagen so that
the machines can process it homogeneously
and in our case we have
converted the machine so that it
has an agitator in it and we
can do without this karagen. The perfidious thing
is that this karagen
prevents it from happening  Cream on a tube frames
that the karagen does not have to be declared according to food law,
which means
we don't use such additives, um,
but we can differentiate in the because you
asked, you can
actually see that, but
unfortunately you can't see something like that on the list of ingredients,
but in the  So
we just do it with radicalism and consistency
and that's why we would
convert machines, that is, the question can be done
so easily, it's not that
easy because then we really
have to convert a lot if you
go to the supermarket and say something
Frozen products, what do you buy there
other than frost? You can
buy something there with a clear conscience or I would
tell you to stay away from everything or well,
you can
find out quite a lot through Google and the
background too and I would always
say first  Of course I do
n't buy Mar products, there's
relatively little that can go wrong, but
the more the products are processed,
the more you have to look. Mhm, how
come, because you just said
that over the years,
a fish processing factory
is still a sawmill, so to speak  as was
the case 60 years ago,
you actually hear about
technological development everywhere, disruption of
new technologies, I would have
said a fish processing factory
that must have changed, there
have to be new machines, there have to be new
processes, but don't seem to
I would say that
little has happened to the fish fingers, but if you
look at our dishes then
quite a lot has happened, there is
a bit of a difference, product by product,
something would change here if at some point
I say that, theoretically, that could
happen if someone were to come across
it  An idea comes and says I'll build a
big ship under Alaska and
produce the fish fingers
on board in one go, but
I think that's extremely unlikely,
not that for a floating factory,
so to speak, in the situation of the sea, so you
always read it as easy  now about
overfishing and when I hear it like that you
ask yourself and you also talk
about fish as a very industrial
commodity. I can also imagine that it makes
sense from your point of view. At the same time there is an
infinite amount of it, either as before
or you buy it  Now simply from
fish farms where
the fish is deliberately produced or
bred or what is the
breeding like? To be honest, you would
think that's good, but that's
actually often even worse because the
farmed fish are also released
Fish that are fished are also fed because
the fish can't
eat plants in any way and that's
why you have to look very closely
and the fish that
has been fished the least, let's say empty, or that is
still very well preserved
is the lasaska
seelac and we use that
90% of the time.  but it will stay that way for the
next few years or is there
likely to be less at some point or so since it is
very well controlled
today I would assume that
it will stay at the same level that has also
been very, very constant over 20 JRE
but it  is the only food that
cannot be grown, which
means we can, there will never be any more of it, there
will always only be the amount
that was there 10 or 20 years ago,
which means you have to be
very careful with this resource
other species of fish that you just got from
the
red one, it's already gone or it does
n't
exist anymore or it still exists but there is very
little and it is now very protected
but these are very, very small quantities
compared to what used to exist, for example  Much more
and today there is the quantity that
is still there, which is now protected, but these
are only very small quantities, so what is
actually crucial is that the
national governments measure the
excess fish, that the fish quotas
and there is also an
international institution that determines
how much  Can you fish so that it is not
overfished and do that
these days? So who is the one who controls
this level of value creation these days? So these
are
fisheries that basically get
quotas and these quotas are assigned by the
governments and the scientists
and they are then monitored
yes then about ships,
I was recently in Alaska with
120 people and then there is always a
government representative on board who
checks exactly whether this is
being adhered to so there are resources so e.g.
alas selx is certainly affected by it, he
is really  Well
controlled with other fishing boats which
we often don't have, you have to
look a little more closely at
sardines, for example atchuis, which are
pretty much freely fished all over the world. There
are also the Chinese out there
and they make anchovies and
sardines out of them  Fish feed and that
goes to the breeding farms and there is
farmed fish and that is rather
critical when I think about it now, you now
have a total turnover of almost 600 million,
then you have 40% of that with fish
then we are not talking about 240 million
with fish like many  Boats are the ones that
buy them for that purpose, so in purely
plastic terms for me as a leash, that's
10 boats that you need to
make 240 or is it 100 boats
or 1000 boats anyway, so I would say
it's an average of 7 to eight
fisheries  worldwide and each of
these fisheries may have
the fish, of course not just for us,
but they may have 5
to 5 fishing boats and these fishing boats are
larger boats that
always have around 100 people
but of the same size  If you
understand this as a business model,
the margin lies in
being good in the processing, so to speak, or L I mean, I
also imagine that negotiating with the food retail sector is quite difficult, you know,
they have their own specifications and
at the same time if you do  When you negotiate with the
big fishing companies, you ca
n't get that
much out of it, so where does
the margin come from in your business model? Well,
actually in the processing,
not where we
turn it into good products that are now special,
a dish that
we add sauces to  If you do then they are
products that are unique and
then taste good and
you don't pay for them in the end and if the retailer
sells them well then they put it
on the shelf but it is still a business where
you
have to put in a lot of effort  So you have to get to 600
million in order to end up with that
is public thanks to the stock market of the
order of magnitude 20 25 million result in
quotation marks, that is, there
are business models, especially in the
digital sector, where you are used to, then
somehow from 6 million turnover
quickly somehow  Margin somehow
30% or so that's not the case,
no, but I think that with food
the advantage is always relatively
stable, it doesn't disappear so quickly,
but the competition is high and the
margin is very small, which means
it stays  In the end, not as much
as it might be in other areas.
In general, I have the feeling that there is
currently a
lot of dynamism in food, i.e. through the B2C D2C
business, which you also do and
then you hear more often
about wfood or Ankerkraut  and
in recent years there have already been a
whole relevant number of new
brands that are coming onto the market and are
getting very big very quickly, that's what I think it's
always been like that, or that's
new, no, I think that was new,
but it's also because of that  I think that
consumers have actually
become increasingly more critical of such large
companies that have thrown a lot of bad products into the market with
additives and things like that,
which then no longer
sell well and of course they
then have a chance or  There is room
for new things that have often made things better,
one has to say not and
that is also very justified and yes
also a good control of the market because
in your specific frozen segment
there is also the Ankerkraut or
the wfood so that is what they are there  We
already have and of course we have
this area that is really good,
we have covered it quite well,
probably if we had done it badly there
would have been many
others too, okay you are
actually the innovators in this
telecommunications segment, so to speak  break the dynamic,
well at least we are in what we
say what quality means,
I think it will be difficult for anyone to
do it better than us and so
I think that's also a question that you
have to ask yourself in the direct consumer business
what you're happy with
so Froster is already the name so
you know that's enough or does it have to
be changed somehow no I think
we're funny is yes we have
at most 10% of the people who
buy us in Germany today  still
very few in relation to the fact that we
are still relatively well known, we are
still somehow perceived as a little bigger
than we actually are
and I think there are
a lot of people who rightly say yes,
so I don't buy a ready-made dish,
I cook it  Just because it
's better that way and I think the people
that are actually our target group are the ones
we have to convince or we want to
convince that if they don't
have the time they will buy us, but of
course they always have a lot of
skepticism towards the
food industry  and
I have to honestly say okay, that means it
's just when you look at
how our lives
or our food has changed in the last 50 years, it's
radical. There were no additives 50 or 60 years ago.
In principle,
nothing like that happened  eaten and today we have it all
at once and that came in an extremely
short time when you say how long has
human nutrition actually developed then it has
built up over centuries and
suddenly within 50 years
we said let's do everything differently
and  Now we do it all
industrially and use additives
and from
our point of view the body cannot
adapt to anything at such a speed, which is why
I also believe that there are so
many allergy sufferers because
they can't cope with all these radical
changes  not
and that's very, very crazy and
I mean, for example, we opened a
small additives museum in Hamburg
10 years ago
because we said it ca
n't actually be that we surround ourselves with
such bad food,
especially with children
who then eat something like that and are then
led to the fact
that they
no longer eat real apples or real bears because they are
completely over-flavored, so
you still eat fish and
meat, so I also cook
a lot myself  but also family
chef, okay, but I'll give you
an example if I put
a kilo of sugar, a bowl of sugar here
like that and then
none of us would just eat it like that with
children, the same way if you put
this sugar flavor and a little bit  If you
put acidifying agents in then you will
suddenly start eating them, which
means only with flavors that
are completely artificial and
have nothing to do with naturalness, even if
natural can be declared with
flavors and any acidifying agents,
you turn them into something tasty that
people like  eat and that is of
course extremely bad because you
are ultimately pure sugar, which means
you can
seduce people with additives and you can ultimately get them
used to something like that and that and that is
extremely bad for the body in the end
and that becomes in the
Food industry then because it's
cheaper
to replace real cheese with a cheese flavor, that's
how it's done and since I do
n't even see it on the packaging because
I can then declare it as a natural flavor,
it's often done
and that's how we feed ourselves  We just feel
bad and that's why we say it's
best to cook for ourselves and
if I don't have time then
you can take another dish from us
mhm but hey you'll continue to eat
meat and fish and so on. Yes, so
I'm eating now  less meat
but that's more of a personal thing. I
think that these meat substitute products
are also really bad because they're
usually made with a lot of chemicals,
but that's actually a
secondary topic. I think it
's basically about
eating the way things do
occur in nature, well, and that
consumers accept that and
now also accept it from Forester, I say
from my point of view when I
look back when I started with
fish fingers,
no one knew the Froster brand, it was completely unknown,
everyone only knew Captain Iglo and
I find it quite astonishing how well known Froster is now, either
through television or
simply through the brand
in stores or not. We have
also been doing television advertising for a
long time
In proportion,
of course, we make less than the other
big ones and I think the product
gets around more by
trying it and
spreading the word, yes, but you also have
vegan fish alternatives and SAS that
does exactly the job, but that was also the case, for example.
Good topic, we've only just
started this because at the beginning
we saw what's in there and
tried extremely hard to replace the real meat
and replace the taste
with flavors, which then
you really say is actually the
bad product  then replaced by an
even worse one because
actually the meat is the meat
is imitated with flavors and
some thickeners and in the
end I don't eat anything good. I do
n't eat meat but I definitely do
n't eat anything better and that's why we
said if we do something like that then we'll do it
In our case we really imitate the fish
with salsify with
cauliflower with arable soil but
without without any flavors
then it doesn't taste exactly like fish but it's
based on really natural
ingredients I mean in the end it's the
old question do people really want
one  So having higher quality
in both food and textiles
is the same in all industries and do they
actually want to have truly sustainable products or is it ultimately
just the price that is relevant and my
gut feeling is still in the
majority of the population  Price is
also now an understandable criterion
because there simply isn't a lot more money
and then you can't say it would be nice if
but I don't have the money  It's
just that everyone has to be able to
decide and from our point of view
I have to be able to see on the packaging whether
it is a product that
is really natural and then
perhaps a little more expensive or
is there really
additives in it and if I do
n't think that's a bad thing  and would rather
pay a little less for it
then that's okay but I have to
at least be able to
recognize that and you can't do that today.
If you buy raspberry yoghurt today then it
says natural flavor on it
and you think that natural flavor is made
up  But it's not true about the raspberries, they
are made in the laboratory and can only
be called natural because they're made
from some kind of wooden thing, this
whole traffic light that's on it now and
stuff like that, that's all there too, for example the
topic of additives isn't shown at all,
so I can do this traffic light
Can I also manipulate with
additives so that I get an A?
Then I have a lot of additives in it
and it's not a good product, so actually
the communication about food is
actually [ __ ], yes the law, the
food law is wrong and
bad because it
allows the food manufacturers to do things
which are not natural but
present it as if it were. Why is that
because there is a lobby precisely
because the politicians usually don't
understand what it actually means and
because the technical developments
continue and, for example, today there is
no E  -More substances in the
product you see today when you
buy something you see almost
no e-substances anymore because
opportunities have been created
to declare things differently, so a good example is
yeast extract, dairy product, you can pay attention to it, it's
written all over it,
dairy product sounds great
Harmless and positive, however, it is a pure
flavor enhancer. In principle,
whey is taken and it is highly
concentrated so that in the end only
glutamate remains and then
this glutamate is so that it
tastes better or tastes more intense.
The product is significantly cheaper, but it is what it is
SAS like if you drank 200 liters of milk
if you had a
chocolate bar it's really
absurd that now also feels
probably very complicated and
you have to go to the additives museum
here in Hamburg which you
have created so you really have a museum here
like  A lot of people go in every year. I do
n't know, but we actually
tend to have people look at it from the
outside and there are also
virtual tours that you can take, which
is quite appropriate in the Hamburg wholesale market
where the groceries are also available  are
traded but we already have
school classes that go there, for example, that
look at it, but it means that
now there are your top three
nutritional tips other than
cooking yourself, I understood directly with
the raw materials, i.e. with the
vegetables and and and and fruit  and stuff like that,
okay, but if you
're kind of a chocolate person or he gives you other
things that they recommend to everyone,
well, you have to
buy freezer, obviously, of course,
but no, everything that
sounds kind of strange, whether it's a hefeex, all
that  which I ultimately
wouldn't use when cooking at home. I'm
very critical at first. I'll also
google it because, as I said, you'll find out
a lot about it and
you have to be super careful with flavors anyway
because flavors are
basically just a substitute  of expensive,
good ingredients, which you haven't succeeded in doing,
both here Felix and my
daughter
Frederike sometimes talks to
politicians and tries to
explain to them that they actually
have to tighten these laws, but
you haven't succeeded at all in doing that, no,
exactly what we have  This has been
trying for 20 years to ensure that
food law must
become more transparent and these opportunities for the
consumer to recognize this. A good
example is, for example, when you buy tea
you always see
a slogen ST always flavored on the front
whenever flavors are used
Right or this
obligation only exists with tea
for some reasons that are completely
inexplicable but if you
buy sweets for children or yoghurts or whatever
frozen meals then you can put the flavor
in the back but you don't have to
write it on the front and that's it  The
consumer practically doesn't recognize
it or that is trivialized because you then
write down dairy product or yeast
extract or natural flavor.
Sounds super harmless but has
nothing to do with naturalness
You embezzle from us, you were a
chef in a star restaurant in
Paris, so not somewhere, a culinary apprenticeship, that
sounds a bit like somewhere around
the corner SN, that was kind of a high
level
chef, you then went back to the company
and then this idea came to me
to say okay  We're trying to
somehow free ourselves from the trade and
try to sell direct to consumer.
Again, that's a big
decision. It's a very
unusual decision.
What was that, what was the calculation behind it
?  After completing my training
I
worked again in Italy, worked at a pasta maker
and I always wanted to
have something to do with food and of course frost fits in
quite well and in the end the cool thing was
actually just
that I always wanted to  I somehow had
to make food the way I
eat it myself, so it sounds
a bit banal now, but in the end
I always thought that when I learned that in
the kitchen and that two-
star chef who was in France
wasn't because of it  Everything
was just really good, what
was interesting above all was that he
actually made something out of everything he bought, whether it was
bones or seeds,
that is, the
stock is cooked from the seeds
and that is  then the base for the sauce,
that really means you use
everything but always
with natural ingredients and then
I somehow just found it
fascinating to think about how can I do
what has been done traditionally for
centuries  You can
also do this on a large scale on an industrial scale,
but in order to be able to do that
you have to have a D2C business in the end,
so you have to sell directly to
the customer, which
is of course difficult with trading, but ultimately
trading is for us  Of course, a little bit like this
helps us in the end to
reach the customer logistically,
so retailers naturally only put
things on the shelf that they
can sell well where they also benefit,
but in the end our interest is in
the end consumer and
we communicate with them  So do we and
in the end he has to decide what to buy
and how does
TV advertising reach him directly? How do
people come to your shop? How do they find you
directly? Actually, we started
a blog before Facebook
then we
wrote really openly about things
and we, for example,  Also for the first time, also at the
very beginning, back in 2004,
product reviews are made possible directly
and today you can
rate a product today and I see it immediately
on my cell phone and it is not
moderated in any way, which means you can
rate it and it will also be
published immediately  This means that
consumers have the opportunity not only
to write something but also to
read what others are writing and to
be in direct contact with us via a blog and things like that. You can really create
traffic where you can then find thousands of
products  Yes, I think you can,
of course we have the advantage of
having permanent visibility
in the supermarkets too, so the
products are there, you walk
past them and see them and
of course you have people who eat the food and
recommend it to others, but of course  If you
want to win millions of people then of course you have to
do television advertising and to the
extent that we can do it and
we have money for it, we do it too but
it only goes step by
step but is it
profitable?  To send food like this across the
country, if you
calculate it like that, how much
transaction does it take, you mean specifically
the freezer shop, yes, I mean clearly D
that the shop sells everything directly,
okay, that's very
special, that's it  yes, still very small,
but we believe that the
possibility that you can have it delivered directly to you means that
you are no longer
afraid that it will now thaw from the
supermarket to your home - these are
all advantages that we then deliver through the
store  can and that's
already
on the small scale it's already
interesting and it works
but of course it's still small it's
the big one but we always only remain a part
not so I think karebe will still be available through the
grocery store
where you can
see the products  and you can buy in passing,
that will always be the case, no, yes,
but of course there will be
people, yes of course, who then no longer
want to shop every day, who really
want to have that delivered, who
need a large selection, we have
100 products of them, you can find  Not even
half of them are in the supermarkets and they
want to have everything. You can only find that
in our shop. Actually, there is
n't that big of a product. You hear that.
I would have guessed that
there are a lot more than 100 products, maybe there are 120
now, but it is  It's clear, but that's
a lot if you don't mean
that it always only consists of one ingredient,
which in turn consists of 10 to
20 different ingredients and then
you suddenly have 500 ingredients.
Look at the dynamics in the
food and  Ask yourself how
things continue to develop, I mean
grillas and and and animals and so on,
they've all tried to
change something, which has
hardly worked until now. Now there's a
picnck, but otherwise the trade has been
quite stable over the last few years  Do
you think that I can do something, so I
wouldn't be so radical, but
of course there are also things like hello fresh,
for example, which are also very big where you
sometimes wonder how it
works and we believe that we
can do even more  and of course we observe this,
I mean we also have permanent
contacts with the supermarkets and and
and they also tell us a lot, so
we know relatively well what's
going on, so actually when you
hear that it's hello fresh, so to speak,
maybe for you too  It was a huge
missed opportunity because what they are
doing on a large scale is
actually very close to your model of
inventing or preparing dishes with pre-cooking,
but
with us it is much
easier to prepare something
and hello  Fresh is perhaps
more of a staging that you
cook at some point because you
enjoy cooking more than
eating afterwards. In our case,
people say that I can
make a complete dish myself in 10 minutes more, of course  Everything is
already packed and everything has to be packed
individually, but actually it would
have been a bit of your DNA what they did there. Yes, I
think that's really different. I
think that's one of the things where you
celebrate cooking a little bit
and with us it's really like saying I
want to eat just as well as if I
had cooked myself but without any
work and still have something
that in the end tastes the same as if I had
but if you couldn't have imagined
that they would get that big,
probably not  especially because there is so much
packaging waste there, so it
actually surprises me that people
somehow still seem to
accept it and that's I mean, they
've even made it in the USA
now, well America, I think
it's always a little bit different, more and
more  Everything is a
bit oversized in terms of space, but in
Europe it's astonishing, so
I always find the
topic of garbage to be an issue. What should
I say now? How do you get the V further developed?  I
was asked by PR equity or by
some people whether I
wanted to sell, but I assume that's the case with
most profitable companies and with
you too, but that's not an issue for us,
so we are
aware of AG Aktiengesellschaft in order to also
show both customers and suppliers  but
also the employees, how does
the business work? We are actually
different from, for example, such typical
family businesses from ötker,
you never know what they actually say, yes, they
say sales, but
not otherwise, so we actually stand by that in
exactly the same way as we do with the products
to be transparent and we think that's good. We
also think it's good that employees
can and do participate
and that's really a lot of fun
and we have a
lot of fun at a general meeting where we
sometimes ask critical questions where the management
also sometimes from  The shareholders are critically
questioned so that yes, but everyone knows
that we won't sell, that's
not why we are shareholders, a stock
corporation so that we can
approach the capital market and also
collect money, so we have the
majority in our hands and that's also
my personal opinion  Conviction about
how many percent
of the company belong to the family, over 50% over
50% and it will always stay that way
and I'm currently in the process of making a kind of
family scourge that I'll
take over my shares too so
that they can  We all
want to remain family business owners and
so we are perhaps a bit
atypical, on the one hand, a
listed stock corporation
on the one hand, and yet, on the other hand,
family business owners. Most
family business owners, as I
see it, are
very reserved with the
numbers. We consciously don't do that, we
think that's a good thing  Basically, if you like, it's
almost a
certain political conviction. I think
companies have to open up, they
have to show what they earn, what they
do with their money and ultimately
with the customers' money. I think that's
good, but we  I've been approached from time to time,
yes I can
say, sometimes approached by Nestler and did
n't want to sell and there is
also a family businessman
Wagner who I knew personally
who then sold to Nestle and
one of us in the  In the original phase, he
was still involved in the ships, he
was a friend of my father's welder, he
owned the company, he also
sold it, so that won't happen with us
and I'm sure we won't be there in my
lifetime. I'm also pretty sure
we won't be there in my children's lifetime  not responsive not so what
sometimes I really ask myself what what what what are they
doing what do they want to do with the money so I think it's good to
stay invested with the money in innovation
invest in something new invest in something new
there are still many markets
that Froster could open up  In
France, for example, we are not represented at all,
there are still many countries, so there
is still a lot to do here for the
next generation, as you say,
what are we developing further or Where are
we still not as I
said, we are at the moment  still
very small, i.e. 10% of Germans buy
us in the first place, so the
chance of convincing more people
of what we do is
relatively large and that's the good thing that
I'm now observing here
as a father, so to speak, on his behalf  onr yes that
too but that's also just
fun i it's fun to cook
develop food and also
sell it it has to be fun for you
not if that wouldn't be fun for you
then maybe it makes sense to
say yes I'll sell it  Loading and I'm
happy that I have the money with
which I can travel around the world, so
that's not what we want, what
I want, what he doesn't want, what our
children don't want and I hope that
your children will take over that too,
not that  We're still young,
no, they're still very young, well,
my daughter's children, they're
all over 20 now, so they don't come
in for a while, but they're all there
and doing an apprenticeship, so my
daughter is currently studying economics
and that  others are studying agriculture,
which is also very good and yes,
Benjamin also
studied economics, studied economics, so
everyone is economically oriented. Nobody
says I am, unfortunately you can almost
say I'm not an artist, I'm a
violinist and business doesn't interest me
and I want it  Selling so
everyone is in the business is
interested in the business and I hope it will
stay that way, but the company has had a
certain dynamic in terms of sales in recent years,
so it went
up quite a bit during the pandemic and then a
year  down again and now I've
looked at the half year figures there is the
forecast it's going up again where does
this fluctuation come from is it also
due to the pandemic or yes it's coming so
the market is also difficult we also
had these times where things
got incredibly tight  With the raw materials
that were extremely expensive,
the costs and things like that didn't explode all of a sudden,
for example, to hold on and then
try to pass on the prices is
also very, very difficult, as you
said, even with life with the
chickens, it's not that everyone says it's great
immediately the prices are
increased immediately, of course there is a huge
discussion and that's why it happens
from time to time that you
have bad years and that's why
you always need a little
cushion so that you can keep it up,
but you're aware of that  Sales and everything have been
reduced a bit in recent
years in order to
somehow, well, work more healthily,
so that people say we do
n't make sales just to somehow make
sales and if at some point you
can no longer cover the costs, then we will increase
Even with some deliveries it's
simply out, but can you make a billion in sales with a
company like yours in the future?
If I say
10% of the Germans' hands, that's
actually what convinced us in the first place and
I think potentially if you
were to sit down Z people and  Questions that
don't know Froster, I think
a lot of people would try it and
buy it again, but of course we have to
reach them and that just takes time.
I feel a certain complicity with the colleagues from Rügenwalder. I had the Godo Röben
here a few months ago
Many years in the podcast and it's
told a little bit about him, he was the boss there
but he wasn't part of the family and he
's now out, but he
also changed this company a
lot, very much as a
front runner, somehow geared towards vegan
The one from the
sausage manufacturer at the end used to be something like that where
you exchange ideas where it's close. Yes,
we always have a lot of
opportunities to exchange them. We
also exchange ideas with people who
do completely different things
and he's one of them  We've just
heard of it recently, but
I think we have this
specific way to be honest. We have
no additives, no flavors and
things like that. There are actually very
few people who do it the way we do,
so we don't have any options for things like that
yet  really
found the partner with whom we
can exchange ideas so well and the trade g is
n't really right either, so the
people at trade are great because the
trade is like I just said, it
's always Dr overze stuff to
have products that are different  also sell well and
they have basically they
are happy if there is someone
who does it in such a way that the customers
also buy it, so he has it, he is
very happy to do it, but let me tell you, there
are no other options
even closer to that  To expand or change the model in some way,
except now
online sales, we just
talked about it, it's small and difficult
because it's somehow profitable. Yes,
I assume the right on the first
transactions because the
goods are small then with the
cold chain and so on  I ca
n't imagine just
doing that, which means you're
somehow stuck between these two shopping
and and and and retail, is there
any way to break out? I
've read, I think I once had
a restaurant or something in Hamburg,
at least that's it too  yes,
probably not enough to break out
of this dilemma, yes, absolutely,
so I know the great chances are
actually to go to another country.
We did that with Italy,
we did it with Poland, and
of course that automatically creates
big new markets there  It's
worth it more than it is now
with a restaurant, that has no purpose for us,
that would make it
easier for us, but then again
the value creation levels are
the same, so you'll
probably also come across
food retail
chains that are now acting relatively harshly
or are exploiting their position of power
Of course, of course, but we
also notice, for example, that when we introduce such a
big new category,
we haven't done fish sticks for
at least 15 years,
and now we've done it again
and for sticks there is a
big
category and that if  If we then go
in there and only
have a small part of the market,
then for us that means
big jumps in sales and can you
boost the brand in some other way
so that people understand even better
what you stand for, I mean like
Captain Iglo  This captain
probably made him worth millions
because everyone thinks he's a likeable
captain and so on, and that's what you immediately get
in your
head. We have Peter von
Froster, he's been given a bit of a new
boost now in a
new campaign  starts and
and of course we always look at
what other areas there are where where
you can do even more, you
can work together with tiktok
to convince any influencers these days that they can
somehow push your dishes or something like that  If you
look closely,
which people are
actually really interested in good food because
you just made it yourself, the large
number are still interested in cheap
food, and we
are actually the ones who we have to
find, who say I'm happy to give
10 cents  20 cents more for me to
eat something good and find it at Aldi,
you can also find it at Aldi, absolutely yes, you can
actually find it everywhere
The closest thing is like this and I think
you can find them everywhere, but you have to
meet them more in communication and
you just have to choose the right channels,
but of course a social
media channel that is very specific can
work better than
TV advertising now, i.e. 80  Millions of
Germans how many how many do you think
are more likely to eat consciously and would
spend more and how many are just
the masses ah I would say 20
million but once we
have 10 million that's
twice as much but we're doing it now for example  with
the apothekenrundschau there are also a
se 60 million it just doesn't matter,
yes I think it will also be the case
that people
will always save on food but
I think there will be more and more,
maybe in 10 years there wo
n't be 20 anymore  Millions but already 40
because I think I will give more and more people
who will say I
'm willing to spend a little more on food,
but you have to try it once
so that you
actually know why it's
useful and we've only done so
So, for example, Food Pharmacy Review is
such an old medium somehow W you
think D we have a new new advertising
and then we write allergic
to additives so allergic is yes that's
what of course then
people might just be reading the SAS
but you notice  that actually
when it comes to eating healthily,
it's actually something
that everyone is interested in and especially
when you have a society like
ours that is also getting a little older,
the healthy
lifestyle will actually become
a bigger issue in the future  What
about your white label product? You
also do a lot with the
white label goods that are then sold to Aldi and Co.
But they are just as
healthy and and and and produced to the
same standards as everything else.
No, you set it yourself  set
the standards because that's how we
buy, we're practically tenders who
say the same, that's a product that
we have and say exactly the
specification and then we bid on that
and then we produce it like that, but
that's its own business
You have to define
how you want it to be that it's hot
but there are already some additives
in it then you don't know that it's not
frost but then it can be exactly yes
okay but that's not up to us it's
their decision to do that  the way you
want it but you deliver it, yes of course if
we ran it if we delivered it to you
then we deliver it the way you
want it they wouldn't
buy it any other way okay okay but you
also notice how difficult that is, so
to speak  To keep the line completely through,
yes, of course, but good, I
mean, but we actually separate that out.
When we say we're
talking about frost and the cleanliness requirement,
then there are very clear standards, it's
clearly defined what we do and
when we say we have  Capacity and
do that for commercial markets
then you define for yourself what you
want where do you have your factories
in Bremhafen I think a Bremerhafen
then one in Bobenheim near Worms
we make herbs right there
in the agriculture around it
then in  lomatsch there is the
lomatschaft in
East Germany near maisien and
a plant in Poland in bütkosch aha
exactly four who are between the second largest are
not Poles
n larger exactly so two plants only
make vegetables,
you can say they also have their own fields
around them and they  The other two plants
tend to make fish and dishes and how
many people are currently working for you in
the fir00 of which the majority are in the
factories but yes W I estimate
a certain 1300 100 or
yes okay who do you see as the
most important competitor who is for e
We already said Iglo, it's
certainly Findus in Italy, these are the
big ones, okay,
exactly, someone will be coming soon, but
ultimately, of course, every
restaurant is theoretically a
competitor because in the end it's
about what people eat and you have
endless possibilities
to eat but is not such a
restaurant to die too currently
to determine where where there is always little left that
you then somehow no
basically I think the opposite
is the autofor so what you go to
outside that is at home tends to be
bigger that was  Yes, because of the pandemic, it
's completely different again, there
was no such thing as that, but now the trend is basically, for example,
if you also look in America,
I think that autofor who has
already built New York apartments, they do
n't even have a kitchen anymore because you say
the people  You only go out to eat outside anyway
or have it delivered
so the trend is that ultimately you
are too dangerous, that's
exactly what it is or you have
a small kitchen where you just
heat it up, that's possible  us
too, so in this respect I think this market
is the same with us, we
now notice, for example, a lot of people in the
home office who
buy something from us at lunchtime, which I think is
also something where the smaller offices do
n't have any at all  There are more canteens where
they can buy dishes
from us, so if you really think about it,
I think that's the
trend, I think it's somehow
going in our direction, it
actually depends more on how we get
it that we people  also really draw
attention to us and let them
try it because
in our case trying it is the best
advertising then okay so the brand is
also growing very positively which we also
reported in the
results reports and you gave
a number like that  Is it even
conceivable to go from 600 million times to a
billion? I think it's certainly
conceivable in the next year, not the
next year or the year after that,
but in a few years, but it
's not our main goal either. You have to be
honest, it's our main goal
that we first say that we
remain true to the quality and that we say that
we will keep it up to the
standard and the other things will come
automatically, so I do
n't think we are the ones who say it
has to
become more every time  Shareholders are also
relaxed, so they don't want to,
well, but they also have to, they
're also interested in ensuring that
it doesn't just become an air bubble where
we then spend a lot of money on advertising,
which afterwards doesn't really become a reality in the long term
No,
I do believe that certain stability
is not the value for us
and it is not the case that
even in bad and difficult
situations, if you say that you
are in a crisis mood anyway, maybe that's where
we are in Germany
In proportion then it's still relatively
good, you sometimes wonder or
maybe even get annoyed that in the
last few years there have always been all these
unicorns, i.e. some young
companies, some of them tens of years old and
suddenly worth a billion or even
more
and you've been doing it since  Generations of this
business and
also changes an industry and or
from the seafaring to now such
a journey and in quotes you are
not yet worth a billion
on paper and then you think to yourself
what is actually going on, how can that be
or have  I did it wrong, yes,
so sometimes when you
see companies like beyond meet or something like that in America, they
are actually relatively small and
don't make particularly good products, at
least from our point of view, but they are
worth a lot  But that's
often over again quickly, and you can't see
it right now. They
're only
somehow 20% of the highest value, so
that's not put into perspective
over time, but of course  At that
moment you start to wonder, you're
absolutely right, but it's no coincidence that
we say we want to have the highest possible
market value, we want to produce good products
and ultimately not only
satisfied customers but also
satisfied employees and
it's fun for the employees
they won't suddenly be surprised
and or now comes to private equity
and is bought in and turns the
whole place upside down. So I think
our employees also have this security
and think it's good that we are in this respect, yes
you can also see that the employees are
happy  that they do
n't like to eat the products themselves
and that used to be really terrible
where you would think that if I
made something for you for lunch then
people would look at me and say
I've gone crazy, that I'm
our products, it was really absurd
you, no one ever
ate a foster product with us when we did
n't have the reinersgebot back then.
It was crazy, so it was already right, so
it was now wasn't a joke
but was a reality and that's
actually more fun than being
somewhere in  the Börsenzeitung looks
oh now you're worth a few h million
more and we also have and,
funnily enough, yes and we also have
a lot of people who come to us
and also work for us and who
then tell us yes,
I would have at remzmer now  Somehow I earn 50%
more but I still
prefer to be here, so you also notice and
that's also an issue: how can you
get people new employees? They of course think it's
good if you make good products, those
where they stand behind them and  and where
you don't just have the product itself and there are
many other
topics, now the topic of packaging, there
are other things that
are also important, so the topic in general is
also the transparency, not only
that we are a corporation but like that  you do that
now, that the employees are
informed about
numbers, there are no secrets, I
think that's
also fun for the employees, so that's exactly what happened, for example, the
development of this purity law was
really so that we developed it,
but because we all did  Let everyone
help develop it in the
really big crisis that we
had, but everyone still said no,
we have to stick with it now if we had
specified that and said we're going to
do the purity law and that's
how it's done and then a
crisis would have come, of course everyone would have
said yes, look, the idiot is telling us
something and it doesn't work, that's
clear, but the moment you
involve them and it's ultimately
the employee's idea to
implement it, they have to implement it at
the same time  suddenly stopped
working and said no, but it's
still right, we have to
hold on now and we had to lay off 10% of the
people and they still
said no, let's carry on, so in
that sense it's also a good learning
from the fact that you say you have to
also how can you actually
overcome such difficult things and
it's only possible with the people and to do that
they have to be able to participate
otherwise you've lost from the start no
now you're somehow Dirk 86 how
active are you so company how are you still
everyone  Every day you go to the office or or every now and then or
what is it like, I
have my own little office, which is
independent here,
yes, where I do my own thing,
I go there, yes, I feel, yes,
I feel quite comfortable, yes, okay  but
is it in Hamburg ABS
10 minutes 15 minutes
away from my home, yes I
like to go there and go there at 8 a.m. or do
you have to imagine how do you mean there
at 8 a.m. no that not
necessarily but um  9 a.m. or 10 a.m.
varies. If the weather is nice,
I like to sit outside on the
terrace and come later and if there's
something specific like today,
I'll be there a little earlier, yes,
but
as long as I feel fit, I can see
why  I don't do it that way, do
n't you really feel the need to really raise your feet up, no,
that would bore me, I would be
bored yes yes, so I think it's a very
positive view of entrepreneurship
to build a family business like this and to
be sustainable, so to speak  In the
structure you also like to hear it
because of course people often
talk about exits and sales and
I think it's okay, but
I find it kind of likeable,
I'm keeping my fingers crossed for you that
it continues like this and somehow
always  more people try Froster
and that you can develop this number,
the 10% let's
take a look, so maybe it's a
very attractive investment for someone listening,
I think you at least know what
you're investing in, we don't
do any investment advice, but
at least you have  Now I think I have a
clear feeling what the disadvantages are
and what the challenges are. Um,
thank you very much for
coming. Yes, it was an
interesting conversation, it was fun.
You learn again and again just by asking
questions. You learn again and again what
is actually important
I always think it's important to you, yes
thank you very much yes thank you ciao ciao this
podcast is produced by
podstars at
OMR